. Now, I mentioned there that Jeff Mason reported
on some of the things Trump said about Dr Foushee
during that campaign call a later in the day.
Donald Trump actually called Jeff Mason a criminal
for asking him a question. The authoritarianism
that we are seeing from Donald Trump has not
been funny for a long time, but now it's
taking on a more vicious and disturbing
tone. Donald Trump yesterday on his way out
to his various rallies, I believe there were
multiple rallies in Arizona yesterday,
called a reporter a criminal
for asking him a question. This is
how bad it has gotten. Take a look.
He seems to be caught by a criminal.
Why is that he is a criminal.
He got caught his laptop and you know, he's a
criminal. You're a criminal for that report again.
You are a criminal for not reporting it. Let me
tell you something. Joe Biden is a criminal and
he's been a criminal for a long time. And you're
a criminal in the media for not reporting it.
Good luck to everybody. Have a good time.
So Donald Trump said he would lock up Hillary
Clinton during the last campaign. He wants
to expand libel laws to sue media outlets
more easily. He said Barack Obama and Joe Biden
committed the greatest political crime in history.
He has kicked reporters out of the press
briefing room. He said a few days ago that
if he's reelected, he will lock up the Bidens.
And now a reporter who asks a guest, Jeff Mason
from Reuters, asked the wrong question, according
to Trump, isn't asking the question Trump wants
asked. He now is a criminal. This is not funny.
This is not a joke. This is the greatest attack
on a free press and on due process that I remember
from any president. Now, if you have an example of
a president who has been more hostile to the press
and more authoritarian in terms of saying that
his enemies should be locked up, let me know and
I will I will examine that. So then take a look at
this. Fox News goes back to discussion about what
you just saw. Did they expressed dismay at Donald
Trump calling a fellow journalist a criminal?
Now, did they express outrage at the authoritarian
insanity that has taken hold? Now, Fox News, in
reaction to that clip, criticized reporters for,
as they say, trolling Trump. Here is Karl Rove
coming in to say the problem is the press.
He also just said that Joe Biden is a criminal and
he has been for a long time and that the reporters
are a criminal for not reporting that he did not
seem like he was in a great mood. I have to say.
Well, you wonder why he keeps doing this with
the press, because they know how to get under
his skin and they troll him, they don't talk about
the issues that he wants to talk about. They're
talking about the issues they want to talk about.
And so maybe he's better off giving them a message
from the podium and not making himself so readily
available. It's amazing how available he is,
particularly when compared to his opponent.
Wow. The president just attacked a reporter
for asking a completely reasonable question as a
criminal, surely freedom loving First Amendment
defending Fox News is going to call it outright.
Now, the problem is the press. And the problem is
that Biden is in his basement, really dangerous.
What's going on here? We really can't afford
another four years of this. And I will say it is
nice to see Trump unraveling so publicly if it
helps remove him. And if it horrifies voters into
either staying home instead of voting for Trump
or going out and voting for Biden, that's the one
possible upside. But if all of this is and capped
with book ended, maybe is a better phrase with
Donald Trump getting reelected. We have a very
ugly four years, 44 years ahead of us. And, you
know, jail everyone is Trump's new thing. And
he does seem to recognize, at least looking at
his rhetoric in recent rallies, that Biden may
well beat him. Starting to talk about, you
know, North Carolina, if you don't vote for me,
I'll never come back. I might leave the country
if Joe Biden wins. But threats to jail your
political opponents. This is something we. Sure.
If you're a student of history and of 20th century
geopolitics, you would know that this happens.
There are threats to jail political opponents
and sometimes it even happens. But for this
to become so common and to the point where
Trump supporters cheer it in the United States,
it's very, very ugly. Desperation may be setting
in in some sense, but if we don't get a
different outcome than we got in 2016,
we're in real trouble here. We're going to
have more on this on the show's Instagram page.
Make sure you are following David Pakman show
on Instagram and follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman or video of me voting. Very powerful voting
video. The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.